my name is Lu D'Andrea and today I'm
gonna be giving a talk on dynamic module
dynamic module is the technology that we
built alongside manipulate back in the
day and we've never focused on it and
one of these talks so I thought it was
time that we addressed some concerns and
point out just how wonderful this thing
is this will be a this will not be a
high level hand waving look at all the
pretty pictures kind of talk this is a
low level you know get your hands dirty
because you know you want to build
something kind of talk so feel they're
there are lots of other talks going on
today so this is one of them so why did
we decide to build dynamic module in the
first place well we had module we have
block we have with we have other scoping
constructs module is the one closest to
what we wanted to use for interfaces and
it's great module is wonderful module
gives you nice lexical scoping where you
have local variables that can be
referred to only within the scope of
that module and it does this this naming
change so you have local module
variables they get renamed before that's
evaluated to ensure that those scoping
don't escape the the module so here is
just a simple module example that shows
the evidence of that scoping so the
internal the fully localized module
variable name for this guy is is
actually stored in the kernel as far
dollar number so this is good for
scoping it also has this temporary
attribute for these local symbols so
that creates a bunch of symbols and then
that's when the module is done it gets
rid of them so you don't have to worry
about memory blow you don't have to
worry about symbols taking up space
after after you're done with them so
here's another simple example that
demonstrates that we have a module that
uses the local variable X and after it's
done there is no X dollar 1584 hanging
around that variable has been cleared
and removed so module is wonderful and
as far as it goes unfortunately it
wasn't quite ideal for building
interfaces what are the things that we
needed that module didn't do and
to build interfaces again this is in the
in the world where manipulate was just a
twinkle in somebody's eye so module
local variable not remembering so this X
dollar 37 using an incremental numbering
system like this ensures that you have a
unique symbol in that kernel session but
it doesn't say anything about that
variable existing in future kernel
sessions or indeed future front-end
sessions so again this this just adding
literally adding dollar number to
something is no guarantee that it's
going to be unique from session to
session because in the next session
numbering starts over also this notion
of of symbols being temporary is no good
for interfaces that need to save their
state we want interfaces to be able to
you know remember that a user has
checked this checkbox or remember that
they've left a slider in a particular
position remember it not only for the
duration of your kernel session but be
able to serialize that into a notebook
and the next time it's opened to get
that information back so we need
persistence which module doesn't provide
and then we also needed a new kind of
scoping where module scopes during the
course of a kernel evaluation right you
enter the module you evaluate inside the
module you exit the module when you're
done the module is gone we needed
something that was able to scope all the
way into a front-end cell so here we
have an example of this note the redness
of the X as I'll be discussing those in
some detail later so we have an
interface that seems to work but this is
not using module renamed variables and
so if we made a copy of this interface
it's going to refer to the same module
variable so now we have two interfaces
that you know if we had to manipulates
that referred to the same variable we
wouldn't want one manipulate moving
around while we're sliding the other one
so this type of scoping for module was
not quite ideal for us so we built
something that was we built dynamic
module dynamic module has a couple of
key utilities that module does not one
important aspect
is that it doesn't disappear when it's
done so module we have you know the
output of a module the fact that this
came through module is gone there's no
module wrapper around the output if you
look at the same content but processed
through dynamic module it gives the same
result but that result is still wrapped
in you know it remembers that it came
from a dynamic module it remembers the
state of local variables when it was
evaluated so we have a scoping construct
that's persistent we have a scoping
construct that stores the definitions of
its local variables not just own values
as module provides but here we have a
local variable that has down value and
what does this look like I use input
form throughout by the way to prevent
the dynamic module from typesetting
because once it type sets then it does
other wonderful things that I'll talk
about in detail but I wanted to look
specifically at the evaluation semantics
just now so we look at the input form of
the result of this evaluation and we see
that not only are the own values
remembered but also the the down values
of local symbols are also automatically
remembered clearly important and useful
as I just hinted at dynamic module type
sets as another scoping construct a
dynamic module box that scopes in space
in the front end so here if we have
let's see we have evaluate this thing we
have a dynamic module box I LUN format
this to show you the dynamic module box
with local state etc and the benefit of
this is if we make a copy of this box
merely by making a copy we have created
a new scoping construct on the screen so
these two these two local X's are not
the same local X just by making a copy
of it I've produced a new localization
construct without typing a line of code
so and this is exactly what one wants
for for instance manipulates you wanted
you want maybe to have several copies
manipulate and visit different points in
the parameter space and different
manipulates and you want them to scope
like this another nice feature that we
built into dynamic module which I'll
talk about at some length is the ability
to have code that runs automatically
when that dynamic module box first
appears clearly useful for interfaces to
run warm up code to get things into a
state where the interface is ready for
the user to interact with it okay so now
I'm gonna walk you through the full arc
of what happens when you evaluate a
dynamic module what happens when it goes
through typesetting and what happens
when it goes through rendering you know
at what point do certain things evaluate
by the way you see at the bottom of this
slide there's a bonus section throughout
this talk there will be bonus sections I
will not be opening those those are in
the notebook for you to look at at your
leisure the notebook is on the
conference website please download it
work through it I think there's some
interesting things that you can find
there and if you need help finding the
conference website ask your neighbor so
dynamic module starts with evaluation
dynamic module has the holdall attribute
but like many functions that have the
holdall attribute that doesn't mean that
it just doesn't do any evaluation it
means it does carefully controlled
evaluation and in the case of dynamic
module that carefully controlled
evaluation is taking the variable
initializers and the payload you know
the interesting bits the body the second
argument of the dynamic module and
evaluating those things within the
context of a module so it does full
localization evaluates them to produce
you know new initializers potentially
with new values it has the result of
evaluating whatever was in the body and
other you know down values and such are
stored here so this is what happens
during the main loop evaluation of
dynamic module it evaluates as if it
were a module but then it returns
something that still remembers that it
was a dynamic module so here we have an
example where we have an initializer we
have a body that changes the value of
the local
variable and then returns the value of
the local variable as a result of
evaluation this gives well the local
valuable has a new value by virtue of
having evaluated this and the result of
evaluating this is an integer okay not
very interesting but but but we're on a
journey here yeah one thing I'll point
out is that initialization if there were
an interesting if there were an
initialization setting here it would not
be run as a result of the kernel main
loop evaluation and I will prove that to
you by evaluating this example so here
we have an initialization which if it
were run would have set X to some other
variable and we see that it has not been
run but it has been remembered to be run
at a future date so initialization not
run that early what happens during
typesetting so after evaluation we
typeset the result we typeset the
dynamic module into a dynamic module box
and pass it off to the front-end and the
important thing that happens here two
important things that happen here one is
that the the very the local variables
are renamed in such a way that the
front-end can detect them and manage
their scoping going forward because in
the box we still have a scoping
construct and so if we look at the
result of here's pure evaluation here is
the result of typesetting and we see the
main difference the only difference now
two differences one is the the variable
has been renamed with some thing that
lets the front end find it later and the
content obviously has been typeset the
typeset form of an integer is a string
the other interesting thing said there
were two things that happened during
typesetting the other interesting thing
is that save definitions is activated so
save definitions true those of you who
have contributed to the demonstrations
project are familiar with it it's a
convenient way to fill up the
initialization option of a dynamic
module or a manipulate that filling that
action happens during typesetting so
here we have a dynamic module that sets
save definition to true and we rely on
this external function H during
evaluation we see there's no initial
here it still saved definitions but as a
result of typesetting we see now that
that's where the initialization so say
of definitions true has now become an
initialization setting that
transformation happens during
typesetting
and I'll point out again initialization
sounds like the very first thing that
would be what that would be evaluated
does not get evaluated during
typesetting nothing is allowed to
evaluate during typesetting as a general
principle if you went to Jason Harris's
talk yesterday you know this so when his
initialization evaluated well finally we
get to rendering the dynamic module box
is sent to the front end the first thing
the front end does other than trying to
show things is look for initialization
options so in this case we have an
initialization that sets a local
variable to the process number of the
kernel and we have a dynamic that
displays that ID and we evaluate it and
we see okay that's a number so so the
initialization is only run so similar to
dynamics dynamic only formats only
evaluates when it's formatted seeing a
dynamic on-screen is the only time when
its contents are able to format likewise
seeing a dynamic module on-screen is the
only time when the initialization is
allowed to format it formats as a result
of rendering and formatting for the user
if there's no one there to see it it
won't evaluate and again bonus sections
I won't be opening during this talk
please go get the notebook and and have
fun okay so one interesting thing about
initialization is that it is guaranteed
to evaluate before any synchronous
dynamics in your dynamic module this is
why it's named initialization because
it's guaranteed to come first if if your
initialization is happening
synchronously which it does by default
and your dynamics are happening
synchronously which they do by default
then we can guarantee that the function
that you define in your initialization
will be present when the dynamic needs
that definition
so and this is a an academic example
that's evidence of that what happens if
you start monkeying about with changing
the defaults either for the
synchronicity of the initialization or
the dynamics well that's when
interesting things happen if you change
your synchronous initialization to false
because say you have a long-running in
it and you needs more than a few seconds
to run so setting in synchronous
initialization to false is the correct
thing to do however that means any
synchronous dynamics in the body of your
manipulate in the body of your dynamic
module will need to be aware of when
does this initialization start is it
still running is a complete yet because
you might not be able to display those
dynamics until the initialization is
complete so here we have an example of
the wrong way to do something we have a
dynamic module that refers to the value
of the local variable X but X doesn't
have a value until later on in an
asynchronous initialization and what we
will see here when I evaluate this is
the fully localized name of the variable
X which is not a very friendly display
to show to your users after a few
seconds yes your initialization
completes and then it shows you the
correct thing but but that isn't a very
user-friendly thing to do to expose this
inner gunk to users so if you need to
run a local a long-running
initialization and if you want to show
users something I'd encourage you to
keep track of when that initialization
is running and display one thing while
it's running and then another thing
while it's completed after it's
completed so here we have another
example that gets into a wait state with
a little animated ellipsis again and
then finally when it's done goes to the
state where everything's warmed up so
this happens more often than you might
think I thought I'd pointed out as a
common difficulty that people have and
we've made this especially complicated
for users of dynamic module by taking
care of the problem entirely for
manipulate so we've hidden this problem
manipulate by having our own custom wait
cursor that we put up automatically
whenever there's an asynchronous
initialization maybe you've seen it in
the past but that's why you haven't if
you're if you're strictly a manipulate
user and you're itching to get your
fingers into dynamic module this is one
thing you'll need to be aware of okay
again bonus slides I won't be opening
this is for you and for the rest of the
talk I'm going to sort of outline some
common mistakes and pitfalls that people
encounter when using dynamic module one
that comes up fairly often is they think
just because they put a symbol into the
initialization option that it is
therefore localized by the dynamic
module that is not the case like module
the only variables that are local are
the ones that you list and the first
argument to the dynamic module you need
to specify which variables are local it
doesn't automatically sort of figure out
which variables you want to be local so
what does this mean this means that you
can drop an initialization setting into
a dynamic module that sets a global
function say to sum through something
and then you have another dynamic module
saying that sets that same global
variable to something else
and notice that out 26 here is Duc when
I evaluate this next guy this now has
changed to rabbit because this season
and this season are the same they are
referring to the same global function so
how do you how do you tell dynamic
module that you want to localize the
utility well you can tell it by
including the name of the utility in the
first argument because that's where you
say where you want things localized and
this is a perfectly reasonable way and
good way to localize things there's
another way that that I will mention
because it's used in the demonstration
site and it's used by our help viewer I
will point out the
presence of an option called cell
context which sets up a default context
in which dynamic evaluations occur or
any evaluation occurs someone could
imagine and I haven't imagined it I've
actually done it
taking the dynamic modules with the
unload season so this is global in some
sense in this expression cell but I've
told this expression cell use a unique
context that's unique to this cell
automatically so even so the context of
season is not global when in this output
the context of season is cell dollar
four seven five or something so in this
way one could imagine having you know
different rectangles on screen
corresponding to different ambient
contexts and localizing things in that
way rather than having them be local to
the dynamic module well question mark
season is going to tell us the
definition from above these guys are in
a different context so I think this is
the interesting question here so here
are the here are the automated contexts
that the front end has created for for
these instances of that symbol yes is
the question that can I set this to a
string is that okay so so the question
is can I set cell context to a string
rather than cell and yes in fact the
global default of cell context is in
fact global but it could be you know my
context 3 or whatever you like note that
that would give it a string it needs to
be a valid context name so it ends in
this back tick okay if if you added that
setting that same setting to the other
cell as well yes this this option can
also be set at the notebook level so you
can have a notebook and this is what's
done for demonstrations for instance and
for our health viewers so that's nice
okay important thing to talk about is is
this red X which we saw earlier in the
in the talk why is it that we say that
this is a likely syntax error
or we're flagging it for special
consideration by giving it this
beautiful red color well remember module
names are temporary they exist only in
the kernel and when we try to provide
them as the basis for a dynamic which
wants a persistent reference to some
variable to key off of those two things
are inconsistent with one another at
their core and that's why the rule of
thumb is that dynamic should never
depend on local module variables and
I'll spell out exactly what that means
with a very nice example that I found on
on this website I think this was
actually from John Foltz gave a nice
sort of summary so when is it okay to
use module and dynamic together well
it's okay if the dynamic completely
scopes your usage of module so the
module is completely contained within
the dynamic it's OK for module to create
a dynamic as long as the dynamic it
creates doesn't refer to any local
module variables same for manipulate you
can create and manipulate you can spit a
manipulate out of a module as long as it
doesn't refer to local module variables
remember these local module variables
are the temporary ones that are going to
be automatically deleted so but these
are cases where you have a dynamic or a
manipulate which implies dynamic that
refers to a local module variable and
that's just no good it's not going to
work it's going to fail for a number of
reasons the question is are there
similar issues with width and width is
is a completely different animal
I would not imagine there to be scoping
conflicts in this way with width we can
we can look at those together perhaps
but right so so how do you avoid using
module and dynamic together don't use
them together you
dynamic module so and the syntax
coloring hopefully is there to help you
remember that okay let's see another
common mistake that I see more often
than I thought I'd see is a fundamental
misunderstanding of lexical scoping so
this comes up most often in manipulate
where somebody has a function that
refers to a couple of variables that are
kind of ambient they're not passed into
the function and then they say
manipulate of my function and they want
to manipulate those variables and they
say well why is my plot empty and these
are not stupid people these are smart
people but they haven't I guess we've we
have a failure of education here here's
the same problem with dynamic module
directly an empty plot why is this well
the variables outside in your definition
of F are in a different scope than the
ones in dynamic module this by the way
happens for module as well so if people
had been thinking clearly about dynamic
module as a scoping construct as a
lexical scoping construct perhaps they
would have gotten to the point where
they think Oh
lexical these things need to be in the
scope of the module in order for them to
work so how do you fix that well the
simplest thing is just to pass the
variables in this case by a value to the
utility so rather than just having f of
X and having a and B kind of be
magically passed you pass them through
directly okay I think we have time for
one more common problem in the case of
building windowed interfaces especially
for interfaces that I've built for our
internal use I find more and more the
need to handle cases where the kernel
quits in an interesting way so we have
an interface that where the user has
built up some state we don't want to
really do that state automatically after
the kernel quits because maybe they have
changed their kernel maybe they've
switched to something else but we want
to let them know that the kernel has
quit and maybe offer to do some
reinitialize ation for them so here we
have an example where I'm using a dollar
session ID
tract the session of the kernel and
being aware of when the session is the
same or different as it was so here
everything's fine until I quit the
kernel watch what happens to this okay
I quit the kernel and now things are not
ok and you could ask the user do you
want to do you want to do something
about that and they can choose to close
the window or they can choose to run
their initialization again and refresh
so it's exactly zero seconds left the
remainder of the slides are bonus slides
and so we might have time for one or two
questions
[Applause]